but we're in this part of my life
so
but it's it's helpful to know
why is that
um I want to talk to you about what I
assume
I'm making a lot of assumptions about
you all now what I assume your dream is
if you're here
but maybe you need an Amazonian river
dolphin
I like the color of your shirt
and and you get this as the output and
that's kind of maybe what people are on
some implicit level hoping for from
talking with the animals
um but are there other ways to think
about communication
and so I found this nice quote as I've
been talk uh reading up on animal
psychology uh animal signals often have
been studied as potentially containing
meaning with referential specificity and
alternative approaches to examine
patterns of responses to closely
measured non-referential acoustic
features of signals many signals can
affect receivers in beneficial ways that
do not require the ad activation of
mental representations which are
analogous to words
foreign
okay so for example you saw me doing
some coordinated music sound making with
some other other hominids
um and here's a vocal Duo
um mated pairs often do this and their
kids learn to do this too with them so
it's kind of like a family if you know
some of those like the Jacksons or some
other family band
um
uh the Von traps for those of you who
like musicals
these are sort of like uh Bolivian Von
trap Family
and and if you start looking into it
there's there appear to be three main
patterns of interaction that people have
been observing amongst the non-humans
um Duets like the TT monkeys we just saw
we also find this in Gibbons sperm
whales and many others these are just
you know examples not in all-inclusive
lists choruses
uh macaques if you've ever heard them
bottlenose dolphin humpback whales
chimpanzees
um I've got a I've got a friend who who
works at the the I'm from Chicago I'm
from Northwestern University uh and uh
they uh
I've got a friend who works at the
Lincoln Park Zoo there with the with the
primates and uh they the the chimpanzees
in particular really enjoy drumming and
and chorusing together so it's not even
just vocals it's
um turn taking and Tiffany the thing
that we generally think of as polite
when we have conversations unless we're
really excited and getting into what the
other person is saying and then it kind
of turns into a chords
um
animals
so are doing Duets they're doing
choruses they're doing antifany animals
have rhythm
you know believe me let's see what the
people at the University of Santa Cruz
have to say
as humans this ability has been seen
previously only in parrots in some
related words sirona is actually the
first non-human mammal to be shown to be
able to keep a Beat
foreign
[Music]
controlling my phone
when we first trained Ronan we used a
simple repeating sound something like a
metronome
once you learn without further training
run was able to find and keep the beat
in complex stimuli including music
okay
the thing I wanted you to notice there
was this this seal is motivated not by a
love of
that music which I do love
um the seal was motivated by getting a
treat afterwards
and so that's a thing to remember and
then I'll come back to
um okay
so we know that they can they can follow
our beat if they want to many species if
they're motivated to
um and there are many species where they
have found rhythmic vocalizations every
species you see on here by the way this
is a teepee monkey again
um our seal friends elephants bats
songbirds various non-human primates and
I didn't put sperm whales on here but
it's clear if you listen to a sperm
whale
yes them too
there have been those studying the
temporal structure in both human and
non-human sound production and this is
actually somebody who was uh
you know
this is from what is this 2017. so the
Deep learning thing hadn't spread
everywhere this is they actually did
this with um
Sports Factory machine kernels anyway
um what they ended up doing with this
and this is kind of a dimensional
reduction that you see here
um
this light colored stuff this bluish
kind of aqua
that's basically pop music
this is basically classical music this
is non-human species and uh for some
reason they were measuring TED Talks
and and what they found is there are
hierarchical rhythmic structures and all
these things but the hierarchical
rhythmic structures within humans vary
amongst their activities their pop music
their classical music their speeches and
non-human species they found rhythmic
structure you know this is a discovery
thing with their
deep learning and their and their
support Vector machines and whatnot so
one could make arguments about and and
of course we're doing dimensionality
reduction so when one could make lots of
arguments about whether the state of
visualization is perfect but
um there is a bit of overlap
and that gives me some hope
there was a question what does rhythmic
structure mean in this context or like
what's a maybe the most marginal example
of a sound that
having
but that's one thing that would be any
any repeating pattern at either a
fine-grained or at a higher grain like
here's
foreign
so they found
amongst us amongst our various
activities amongst but not us and their
various activities that there are not
surprisingly
hierarchical rhythmic structures that
are there and do I even need to mention
Melody how many people have ever heard
of Songbird
how many people here have not heard
whale singing somewhere probably there's
like oh I'm having trouble sleeping and
they get you get told just put on the
whale song
that they actually do that there's
there's like all sorts of YouTube uh
channels dedicated to relaxing male
songs for your sleep if that's who knows
what they're saying about you or or each
other but it's apparently very separatic
okay
so Rhythm Duets choruses melodies
I'm going to revisit this dream
foreign
are dreaming of talking to the animals
I am imagining a world of perhaps
jamming with the animals
let's start that from the beginning
[Music]
oh
let's see
I'm pretty sure we can all agree about a
couple of things here one they are
probably not communicating little
packets of information uh you know that
we can measure perplexity on and things
like this
they are communicating
and it's meaningful I'm pretty sure to
both of them
why is that
solidifying group identity creating
emotional alignment these are some of
the things that we know happen with
music
and
I feel like
like I'm no scientist I'm a computer
scientist right so I mean we're not
really scientists
um but
I look at that last video and it's not
the only video out there I mean if you
start looking for singing with your dog
uh making music with your parrot there
are lots and lots of people out there
attempting to commune I I would almost
say rather than communicate commune with
with the animals in their lives and that
with certain animals and it's probably
the ones that you know there's a reason
that we live with dogs and parents that
maybe we're close enough in some way
that that we can do this with them and
that it perhaps is emotionally
meaningful to both parties or we know it
is to us
um so we jam with dogs you just saw an
example of that why can't we do this
with every species and now I want to
come back to the seal
um a major issue of testing animals with
music composed for humans is that the
tempos and Pitch ranges may not be
relevant to them
there may be species typical ways of
expressing different emotional states
going up versus down louder or softer
you know and some of these species
they're close enough to us that we kind
of get it like if you've ever had a dog
and the dog has been like
but but it's harder you know
you're in Berkeley there there's all of
these crows everywhere they're clearly
vocalizing I got no idea what's
happening there but it's meaningful
um and maybe we could translate yes
[Music]
it's true
we can all get together on figure based
and um
um
so my translation of this
is that we need music translation
and so
some of the things that we want to do at
least I want to do
um transform the rhythmic Timber and
Pitch content of our sounds into more
interesting and relevant sounds for the
Target species
ideally this would work quickly so that
you could try things in the moment to
find a way to engage
and the goal is to engage socially and
emotionally but not
transmitting information like it is
forbidden to park here between the hours
at five and seven pm
that is not something uh I'm considering
now
if it were the year 2010 I'd be somehow
suggesting something with I don't know
Vector machines and random forests or
whatever listen but of course it is the
year 2023 so I'll be suggesting using a
generative language model as the last
talk was suggesting using because that's
that's the tools of the trade today
right
I don't know how many people here are
actually you know machine learning types
so I'm gonna very very high level
explain what a generic language modeling
system does
you have a thing here how many people
recognize what this thing is yeah yeah
so this is the classic image of the
Transformer from the 2017 paper which is
our attention-based
basic building brick that everyone is
using these days for language modeling
and you input some
in the old days you know the 2018's text
in here I want to eat cheese and if you
are
are doing translation say so you'll have
an alphabet or a set of tokens a
dictionary of words say English words
these are put in and you get and the
output of this from say a trained model
some sort of probability distribution
that if we blow up
might be and if I'm doing do people know
what top K sampling is
um if I take the top K candidates of the
my probability distribution say for
Spanish so I input the this whole
sentence and I get my first word out and
here's my top candidates and you see a
probability that's the vertical Blue Bar
associated with each one and then you'll
pick According to some sampling
procedure maybe I just randomly pick
from the top K and in this case I didn't
pick the most likely one
and then that becomes input to the model
along with the original language and
we get a new probability distribution
and we pick from it yeah there's a
different number of dots mean
oh it means that I accidentally put four
dots uh and and two dots yeah man you
know I was putting this together last
night
I felt really good about getting this
thing here and I just didn't even notice
with that yeah no no no there's no
hidden unit for that so I'll go back and
fix that babe
um and as we're going forward we keep
getting new probability distributions as
we get greater context in the new
language and selecting from it
now usually implicit in this there's if
we're going to train these things we
need to have some idea of ground truth
now if we're training within a single
language then you can just do the simple
math language modeling thing you're used
to I take I just say predict the next
word in the sentence and got the
sentence all ready and so predict the
next word did you get it no okay if I'm
doing translation obviously I need to
have some version of the sentence in
another language and in this particular
example here's my ground truth and since
you're asking these kind of detailed
questions these are not to represent
non-zero probabilities these were just
to be placeholders
um
and so the idea here is like the next
word better before man to eat because I
want to say I want to eat cheese
eventually queso
um this will be my ground truth and what
we do is we don't actually compare the
samples We compare the probability
distributions
so we say how close is this probability
distribution to that one
and that becomes our Training Method
as I just said this requires us to know
the right output token and every step
along the way and that has implications
which we'll get to bye
I'll say this is where we were at in the
20 teens
it's the 2020s
how many have heard of Dali the image
generator well Dali 2 is based on
something called diffusion models but
the original dolly was based on language
models
and the original the old school the 2021
dolly
so what you do is you take an image and
you encode it with something called the
variational autoencoder an autoencoder
or some kind of encodile thing and uh
each one of these and it's actually
going to be a quantized one because we
need to have an alphabet a language a
finite set
of things that we're going to learn
probabilities for
we take an image we break it down into
patches of pixels
these patches of pixels are going to be
our basic units the reason we don't use
individual pixels is because language
models have a problem which is that
they're not good at long long attention
spans I know they tell you they are but
they're not
so if you know if I've got a thousand by
thousand image that would make if I've
turned that into a sequence that would
be a sequence a million things long and
that's a problem so they they get
patches
and so you take something that maybe
once had you know 65 000 thing in my
sequence and now it's a thousand and
it's small enough to run a Transformer
on
and it's going to be the same game
like input language
tape you're made of an accordion
generates a probability distribution
over image patches
and those image patches
are Auto regressively generated and that
means I start out now this won't be a
tape here I got this from another paper
so this is going to be a flamingo
um
and one by one I sample away
hundreds or perhaps thousands of
sampling steps later I have a picture of
a beautiful flamingo
and so you see how this goes it's like
this is called Auto regressive sampling
and it's got its pluses and its minuses
um
one of the minuses
is that when I'm generating a lot of
tokens I have to take a lot of steps
you know
um
one of the pluses is it's really simple
to do and it's you get it I understand
how it works
okay
and another minus we'll talk about is
you can't be influenced by future events
it's sort of
this is the whole Bert versus GPT thing
right it's like ah the auto regressive
ones yeah we're
we're from Google we don't use Auto
regressive we're from open AI we do
great exaggeration of their positions
okay
doing this in audio so now what we did
was we started with language translation
and we said okay I've got a sequence of
text outputting a sequence of text in
another language
and then I said we could do a sequence
of text and output images
you can also do this in audio
if we have something that can take these
really long sequences in audio if I'm
sampling it say CD quality 44 000 times
a second forty four thousand one hundred
times a second
if I wanted to predict 10 seconds of
audio let's see that'd be 440 000 uh
things in my sequence which is a problem
again for a language model
so what we do is we use something called
a partner
you saw with the images
in this case however
there's going to be
multi-level
tokens here so here's a Time step let me
see what you see it's not just one took
there's going to be a set of tokens this
just happens to be right now the best
state of the art for uh representing the
audio in a way that when we detonize it
this is not my work this is uh sorry and
it's cut off
um
so far
I'm just sort of building you tasks but
this is one of the keys you know I have
to go through the audio again one of the
problems with keynote as I love keynote
for those things you saw when the
probability distribution went got really
big that was nice that was a keynote a
weakness of keynote is with audio I'm
forced to just play it I can't not play
it so we're going to skip through this
real quick now
okay
um uh this is Soundstream something we
are using Soundstream we're training a
Soundstream model as part of our system
but it's not ours
yes yeah okay so
clearly I put the build in the wrong
order yes we're gonna jump forward
you said it I'm going to go to here okay
um where we started
sex translation English to Spanish
I'm going from text to text
I have matched pairs
and it's straightforward it's
easy to do with with human language
because we've got things like the Bible
and the Wikipedia that provide us nice
oh and the entire European Union set of
laws
which have nice uh especially the
European Union because they got to get
it exactly right across multiple
languages you've got nice paired things
um things like Dali
all of you out there who have who has
ever put a picture on the web and
captioned it
yeah so thank you say the dolly people
right they scraped it and you've got a
matched caption and image pair so you've
got your pair
um there are audio language models
before us which I've skipped ahead of
I'll just mention briefly there's a
audio LM
which does use a tokenized version of
the Soundstream thing that I just
mentioned and it's the same thing they
they've got uh
a language model which is trained on
generating sequences of tokens
there is music LM
which is a little closer to my Realm
but they both audio LM and music LM work
somehow conditioned on text audio LM is
primarily for speech
and so they're conditioned on speech and
they've got lots of labeled speech data
everything from NPR for example
music LM
basically trained a model on on captions
of things like YouTube
videos where you've got the caption and
then YouTube
so all of these things up to this point
are caption of text somehow in your
native language I'll put in something
else text in your native link
in the English speakers native language
and it refers to me that probably half
the people in the room do not speak
English as their native language
same thing audio LM music LM
I don't know how many people have seen
this quote I love this quote
and uh I tried to look up the provenance
and there are so many disagreeing it was
Laurie Anderson no it was Martin Mull it
was in fact there's an active Community
researching this quote to try and figure
out who came up with it first
but it's
it captures something writing about
music is like dancing about architecture
if you've ever if you're old enough to
have read rolling stone when it was
still a thing
ask yourself if by reading a Rolling
Stone review or a critics description of
a song you could tell what the song was
like really
because I generally feel I can't
so there's this
thought that we're going to translate
stuff into
for want of a better word English
and that English will be sufficiently
descriptive actually this is a thing I
was thinking about in the previous talk
you know there's this whole there's a
language and and I'm wondering you know
one of the problems that happens with
machine learning uh
back in the day when we talked about
machine learning you know there would be
like a hypothesis space and one of the
things we would talk about is that the
representational system of your machine
if it is incapable of representing the
concept there's no learning algorithm
that's ever going to get it
and one question I might have is do we
honestly believe that English
is going to be a representational scheme
that could adequately capture the
concepts expressed by another species
even if they're even if they are
Concepts along the lines of what we
think of you were about to say something
case in the agnostic case you want to
get as close as you can to the best
hypothesis in your space of existing
hypotheses in life
for all of us in this room surely that
would be whatever is capturable by
English
language We're not gonna be able to get
better than that anyways
right so
I guess it depends like what you thought
about what is languages mathematics a
language is musical language then I
might believe you if it's just the ones
that we can write down like with the
normal alphabet
then I don't know because I think there
are Concepts that I don't know about you
but it's hard for me to express in
English that I can write down in math
and I I do believe there's
no I want to use the word concept but
there's something that's in music
that I can't write down question and
that's just within my own species
and in general emotions are quite hard
to put down in words right
I feel like there's been a lot of songs
with the lyrics being it's hard for me
to put this indoors which is interesting
uh yeah okay so now we're ready to
preventing that
um that's me
this is the primary architecture
this is pregnancy for ramen
um our collaborator at descript which is
a company that sorry which is a company
that actually works on automatic
transcription of of human speech and
allowing you to edit and regenerate
okay so what do we do well
I told you I was coming at this from a
music perspective right so
this is the conditioning
note I did not write a sick beat
instead you make a sick beat
tokenized by uh residual Vector
quantized bae
these tokens are turned into a
hierarchical
set of things basically the idea I
skipped over this when you asked that
question
[Music]
um
these uh these Vaas the the best ones
right now for encoding music and audio
um you do this thing where you say I I
tokenize I I quantize it first but then
there's going to be some quantization
error and so I then I'm going to make a
set of tokens which model the
quantization error which will leave some
quantization error so you make another
set of tokens that'll model that and in
the case of our our model it's 14 layers
deep but
that's the basic name and somewhere we
are going to arbitrarily not so
arbitrarily but for the purposes of this
I don't want to get into how we choose
um a division of what we call course
tokens which are about long-term
structure and fine tokens which are
about filling in the details of young
this is going to be sent to a language
model
the language model
you see I've I've prompted it with some
portions of the audio mask
this is what the M's are here
the course model is going to get
just the ones below the dotted line
it's going to sample from its
probability distribution given the
prompting
that's going to be handed to the course
defined model
which will sample
based on the prompting again this time
from the course model
we de-togganize and we get out a
different sick beat
so this is already this is the training
this is not training we'll talk about
training this is conference this is
inference right yeah so what is it what
are the model Parts it's the best net
and the
yeah so what happens here is you take
all of them yeah you cover up some parts
of it
and then the uncovered parts
are then well
hoping is tokenized actually because we
really do it up here but
once we cover this stuff up
we can't I can jump straight to the
train you want to talk about the
training yeah so I'm just so for some
reason you do course first and then fine
yep and the reason we do course first is
because
[Music]
um
I've never drawn a picture
one of the things you do when you draw a
picture is you get like the first you
got the bigger structures
I'm going to draw you on YouTube
and then once I've got the overall
structure then I start feeling a little
bit more detail
and so one of the things that's happened
here is we found that it works better
and we're not the only ones who found
that it works better at least in the
audio of the name for some reason I
haven't seen them doing this in image
to go
we are going to first of all do this
hierarchical
tokens
then we're just going to look at the
course layers first Zoom we'll call it
relatively long-term prediction
fill that in and once we've got that
then details get filled in
so what this would sound like if we were
just doing the course stuff is you'd
lose a lot of high frequencies a lot of
the
show up with this in English uh you'd
lose a lot of high frequencies that's
one thing yeah why do you think you lose
the high frequencies
um
in general because
when we're talking about
low frequency waveforms there they make
if we're talking short time they're
going to be a big trend
and high frequency won't be
okay
immediate sense yeah okay well so this
is the game yeah just a quick
clarification so the final level tokens
are fed into the course fine models
right
okay so
yeah and maybe this picture could have
been slightly better done so the deal is
masks unfortunately
put it in here
take the mask only course
feed it to this
this generates something that gets
filled in
then this you're right
this is also provided here in this
installation available
so my bad I'll make a better picture
um okay so this was developed for
musical career
so some of the thoughts here are no text
prompting conditioning on the sound
because we're thinking about sounds
we're not thinking in descriptions of
sounds we're not dancing about
architecture yet we want it to be faster
so I haven't talked about doing that yet
and we want to allow interactive on the
Fly updating in generation and
you know I think I'm gonna
restriction
um
so we have this thing and what does that
have to do with uh
language translation too
the music of other species how many
people know what Laura is by any chance
okay a couple of you
um there's an approach that people are
taking these days to taking large
language models and fine-tuning them on
new data
and so we chose to do that here and um
you know it takes about a week to train
this thing
not
using Laura
um but with Laura you've got a small
amount of data
you can fine tune it for the sound
palette of something else
in uh with just say 10 minutes of data
and six hours of RTX 3090.
that's Insider talk for people who like
to use graphics cards the point is about
over overnight
on your home PC you can fine tune this
model and then once it's fine-tuned you
can use it so here's an example
this is what I imagine okay monkey
wanting to hear from me
um then we take the video the actual you
know that video we saw with the the two
monkeys chorusing that had about 10
minutes of actual TD monkey in it
um it was like a nature video and we
chopped out the parts with the narrator
and just left the TT monkey train the
model and then put this into the model
and get this out
thank you
now no we haven't gone to the Bolivian
rainforest yet this this was like over
the weekend
um so I I have no idea if this would
make a Titi monkey more or less
interested in communicating with me yes
meaning in in the original communication
you intend sorry for assuming that it
wasn't but um then why are you needed in
this why aren't we just like learning a
general for TT monkey sounds and then
generating from it like what sense is
your we did learn a generative model of
PT monkey sounds that's and are
generating from them but the point is I
want to condition it and I think you do
some I thought I saw a hand growing
programs I always like I have poor
spatiality
um but I'll say to you what I want to do
is I want to jam with the monkeys as
close to possible as opposed to I'm in
the middle
yes
um yeah it seems to me and I hope you
can explain this uh a really big
difference between using the van for
time
to then
okay hey
um it seems to me to be I'm a historian
of science so I'm I don't have the kind
of technical
um vernacular but it seems to me that
the input and output of the of the um
the vamp training that you were doing
um could be interpreted in lots of
different ways so there's different
kinds of meaning by making a sound like
boom
um than than like jamming right boom is
has lots of different contextual uses
and then translating it to non-human
kind of understanding of those meanings
so I'm thinking about in um in Chinese I
um you know the four tones uh like Ma
has has four tones and has four meanings
Vamp might interpret that as a Melody
instead of four different words that are
based on Pitch changes so
um music has its own meaning and its own
language and
um it's notes and I don't understand I I
guess like how how you're thinking about
that in terms of textual translation for
non-human others
right I'm not thinking in terms of
textual translation
um
but because because couldn't the monkey
be more than vocalizing but encoding
um I don't know temporalities or objects
into its Melody and how do you
disentangle that
uh two thoughts one I'm never going to
be able to disentangle it
um two I think the entire rest of the
workshop is going to be focused on that
kind of thinking how do I get this
sequence of things that I can turn into
tokens that we'll call English
and
my positionality is that there's a lot
of by the way there's a lot of songs I
know the words to ish
um that the words are I don't want to
say irrelevant
but it's like banana Nana NFL banana
yes the word banana is in there
and also
okay
there's something else going on and and
and my hope and I'm not saying that I'm
anywhere close I'm I'm not an animal
psychologist I am somebody who is coming
at this from like the more you know
there's this other aspect that I feel
like could be in there and I see
interactions with other species with us
that seem to be along the lines of
singing along and I was wondering what
can we do that would make our sounds
more relevant to them so that in this
other kind of mode of interaction and
communication we could
get into it and maybe it's like a pipe
dream and maybe it's foolish and maybe
I'm accidentally maybe I accidentally
said you know
you know how like it's not really cool
for someone that looks like me to say
the lyrics of gangster rap I don't know
uh I don't know maybe I've done a
terrible thing like that here
um
we're trying stuff that's that's my
answer yeah I guess I'm also thinking of
um when Justin Bieber entered uh like
did the collaboration on despacito right
he doesn't know Spanish but he memorized
the sounds of the of each syllable of
despacito in order to sing and he does a
great job
um so he doesn't understand the meaning
I mean maybe he like looked up or his
like publicist like told him the actual
meanings of the words
um but he's producing success so he's
producing you know Melody over over
textual meaning and those things are
combining but he doesn't have the kind
of embodied cognition of understanding
actually what he's saying and so
um
yeah it's it I guess I guess I'd just
love to know a little bit more how
you're thinking about
um melodic like I'll listen to
um uh in Opera and not not understand
the words of the Opera but understand
its emotional valence
um if if I were yelling this at you
instead of like Whispering or whatever
like affecting some kind of
um you know feminine vocalization those
two have really different kind of
context even though the words I'm saying
are the same
and
um so I guess my point is that the the
context for the for the words is always
this um embodied
kind of uh
vocalization and
um that also has to do with music and
and that's a little bit different than
just sound making when you're coding
meaning in what you're saying and so I'm
just a little bit confused how this
transformation relates to what you were
doing before it seems like a really big
leap
oh yeah but um
okay I feel like I want to give the
other people an opportunity to also
because you also obviously and I'll I'll
come back this later no I appreciate
what you're trying to do too and there's
some simple ways that we can do it as
scientists where we can give them
choices we can give them the two the
types of things instead of see what
seems to be more silly and what's more
engaging I'll just hold up on that
because that's an easy way to test on
what things you're looking
um yeah
I would be interested in that showing
your stuff into monkey sounds but the
other way around and if that would be
interesting at all for us if you could
that's a great question if you you want
to illustrate whether or not that would
make sense let's find out
[Music]
um
let's see well this would be kind of a
loop can I do this
you know I'm since you asked that
question that question does bring up a
possibility okay
we're about to see what can happen live
with a assist so we're going to take
I'm going to try and record monkey
sounds or
and uh
turn them into naturalist sounds
we'll see how that goes
wait
okay awesome
that's gonna be my input now
um here I'm just gonna
just gonna make it louder
so I got it no audio selected turn it
okay one sec sorry about this this is
what happens when you do a spontaneous
on the Fly
uh volume amplify
there we go now
okay
now hmm will this work only one way to
find out
so we have a little interface that is
not the most beautiful interface again
this is active development
some uh
call it oh darn it
do you see that there
we go
okay
so I think this is the voice of a
naturalist
and so this is sorry this is a decoder
that's been fine
[Music]
yes
um so we have about 10 seconds of audio
this is running on a PC in my lab on and
let's see what we got
thank you
[Music]
this is what happens when we don't
actually know if that's the right
fine-tuned model
as long as we're at this
um
so I'm not sure what went wrong there
but you saw I was being super super in
the moment
um
we'll use another thing that may also uh
we'll see how this goes
this is me again because
and what one could what I'm imagining
this is you know steps along the way
this is not there and obviously there's
lots of other stuff that we need to
think about
[Music]
thank you
okay
so I don't really know what the burden
model was I thought that was the voice
of the naturalist
um but what you can see here is this is
running now on stuff
um and the thought is that eventually we
could have something that could be going
sort of in an interactive way so we
could maybe explore what what causes
interest amongst
amongst our non-human
hopefully friends
um I'm going to skip over some stuff
since I see that we're you know getting
close to the time yes
a question so can you think of it as
some form of style transfer right and
basically the main structure of the
outputs is the same so that's the course
part of the tokens and the style rifles
yeah yeah yeah I guess I yes I
in the lingo of modern machine learning
people you would call this a kind of
style transfer the reason that I
hesitate to call it style transfers
because I think style transfer
is not a great word from my perspective
when I think in terms of audio because a
lot of times when I think of is the
style is not entirely the fine grain
structure but also larger aspects of the
structure but yes in in modern
parliaments yes style transfer yeah you
think it'd be fair to say like in the
context of animal communication and and
Beyond everything that is being
discussed just over the last 10 seconds
is that you're trying to generate
interaction rather than understanding
like the purpose of the model isn't to
understand exactly what's doing but to
create a space where you can try and
generate new hypothesis about what
generates interaction
it's a really great question
I definitely want to generate
interaction
emotionally positive interactions
possible which is a risk
um
I do not
think that all even human communication
is about the tokens
um I think a large part of our a large
part of our interaction has nothing to
do with the words I'm using all right
got it
it could be
that a large part of interaction has
nothing to do with the words I'm using
and so I think to myself there's a lot
sorry about that no I do perfectly done
Illustrated
um I guess my point yeah what you're
saying is right I think I'm interested
in interaction I think I'm interested in
hopefully finding interaction that
generates positive emotional balance
between hopefully Us and Them yeah and
and I I am almost thinking of the other
stuff as what you all will will will
will provide well because that can feed
into a conjecture machine right and I
feel like you were going to say
something
but he's grabbed the microphone I was
given the microphone okay so you've got
the what's the approval of the
authorities thank you uh this is all
really fascinating by the way I'm really
enjoying the talk uh it seems like in
most of the examples that you're using
uh the rhythmic structure is preserved
whereas the frequency and harmonic
content is altered true so that's just
that's a statement but I'm wondering if
there's something that is fundamental
about
uh communication or or music or both
that is preserved within Rhythm and not
in other other facets
I think is you were you you're very
right that we're more preserving the
rhythmic structure than the other stuff
um that's our own bias and we came from
the original uh purpose of the model you
you heard that it's like drum beat
things in the beginning the idea was to
use this for interactive music
performance with other humans and one of
the fundamental things that is true of
humans is that when you have
um a music performance and and I'm
keeping the beat
I can do almost anything I want as long
as I'm keeping the beat
um and people will will tend to accept
it and so we that is a bias of the model
and the way we built everything I mean
you're but if there's like this sort of
second level to that which is you're
saying how do you know that that's the
right thing to do maybe transforming the
rhythmic structures is going to be the
important thing and so what I would say
is we when I say keeping the beat we're
keeping the course for the next
structure we do vary the fine rhythmic
structure and I could take you back to
those input and output drum beats
we kept the beat but all the details
changed around the beat but maybe that's
not the right thing to do with say I
don't know sperm whales and it comes
from where we started this project and
now how we're thinking about repurposing
it maybe we have to rethink the
fundamental ideas
I felt like you were going to say
something
yeah I really appreciate this talk yeah
I think there is a real intersection
that's becoming evident between when we
try to interact and then we try to
decode because we can get great insights
from those interactions with the animals
to see what Salient what engages them
and then that's the beginning of that
kind of help because what because we're
trying to find yourself Cipher here for
decoding so I think this is it's not one
or the other I think they feed into each
other in a really important way and uh
yeah but I think we're sort of to try to
it's really it's so you know when you
think about what's even Salient to
another animal that you're doing and the
other thing just from the communication
Theory point of view when you screamed
it said what you know what's going on me
much of most of what we do as humans we
think we're didactic but most of the
meaning is conveyed in the power
language the paralinguistic what we're
doing doing body wise with the tone of
our voice and things like that that's
pretty recognized
in terms of human communication Theory
so we have that whole big package with
animals too that we've talked about a
lot today
yes I mean I was just related to a lot
of these things going to ask what
happens if you do the same kind of
translation procedure between things
that are a little bit more legible you
know does it like preserve Awards uh can
I do this to do just like voice
conversion or what happens if I do this
with oh well I mean this same technology
it definitely is used for voice
conversion and variants on it partners
for things like things like this like
like Google's Project differentiable DSP
um is exactly if what you want to do is
play a flute in on one end and here's
something that sounds cello light coming
out that's definitely this text but I
think in the back yeah um I I really
enjoyed the talk thank you
I just sorry was I
don't know
yeah
uh so my question was I think it seems
to me like there's a there's a
fundamental assumption here when we're
trying if you're trying to translate uh
Human music to something that's more
Salient to another species like a teeny
monkey
and you're trying to generate positive
valence in the other species I think the
fundamental assumption is that their
version of music is used in a similar
context to ours which is that so like
with humans like you explain when when
we Jam together that's a form of social
bonding right but with TD monkeys or
really any species that has
um made impaired Duets I would imagine
that when they hear their mate duetting
with them they experience positive
violence but when they hear a stranger
they're gonna experience negative
valence because to them a territorial
song
the the reaction to that depends
entirely on who's making it so if you're
playing back something that's generated
by by an AI that's almost certainly
going to sound like a stranger so I
would actually be surprised if it
generated a positive feelings I would
expect it to generate negative because
they're going to perceive it as a
stranger singing which is a threatening
stimulus to them
I'm just going to jump to our what's
next finding a situation where Jan with
uh non-domesticated species it's
possible is something we'd like to do we
want to try it out and see what we're
getting right and wrong and this is very
important and maybe I'll bold face this
right now
obviously we have to do this in
consultation with people who know a lot
more about the species we're trying to
do this with than we do I do not claim
to know
anything in that realm I'm just an
excited computer scientist slash
musician who thought it might be really
cool to do something that engages in at
the emotional level as opposed to the
tokens of information level
but I would need to talk to someone else
in this room who especially would know a
species extremely well
um before actually trying this with any
particular group of animals because you
you bring up some great points
I know we gotta stop
I think in Dominica but this whole
question of
about passive versus active so I can but
when we talked about active was playback
for the idea that having uh for the
whales uh agreed so like they would
stimulate some kind of chat box and if
they don't like it they don't
they don't do whatever it is that causes
this thing to exist but this is this is
different because you're the jamming is
somewhere in between right it's like uh
it's not just playing I don't know about
in between but it's not playing back but
it's actually playing together it's sort
of an interesting concept and
um
assuming you had a way to figure whether
they're interested or not interested
it would be sort of a
dress with this problem where they're
doing wrong
but I do
acknowledge the fact that when you
yelled okay besides the fact that at the
moment it was scary I am still it
brought me into a different emotions but
I'm still dealing with I'm sorry I'm
sorry no no it's not but I'm just saying
it's clearly very even we don't
understand our own emotions let alone
with the world
um but I think it's one you know I I
feel the urge to find your attention
sounds great
we have coffee now outside for 30
minutes
later okay
[Applause]
foreign